when do you talk about price I got a
great question one of my videos from one
of my youtube viewers adarsh love you
guys and a dark road in to say once you
decide to approach a company what should
one's proposal contain is it okay to put
the price for my idea along with the
points from ideas going so this is a
great question adarsh thank you for
writing in I hate it when entrepreneurs
compete on price entrepreneurs we're
constantly undercutting ourselves we're
constantly shooting ourselves in the
foot and we're not making the money that
we deserve because our prices are too
low and we feel like this is the only
way to compete the reality is you need
to compete on value you need to provide
incredible value to your customers and
not lead with price competing that price
is a loser's game because it's always
going to be somebody who's going to
undercut you it's going to be somebody
who will take a loss who do it for free
to undercut you because they want the
business is always going to be that
person so don't play that game you need
to compete on value to offer a fair
price for what you're providing in
return of the value okay that's really
important so if price is not the most
important thing that you're selling on
then don't lead with it right natural
it's going to come up but you don't want
to lead with price because it's scary
right when when the customer looks at
your prior to somebody else's price the
natural inclination is to go for the
cheaper one so you have to prove your
value so what I would try to do is talk
to them and show how great you are and
prove your value and let them let them
come off with every discussion with you
saying well that guy really knows what
he's talking about when you get them
feeling that then you can discuss
pricing because they're feeling the
value so for me when I do when I do
calls with corporate clients or
prospects people who found me they're
interested you know if you want me to
write a blog post for example I might
write a blog post it's got to be
value-add it's got to help entrepreneurs
and i'll charge 2,500 bucks to do it
2,500 bucks that's not cheap right other
people would charge five hundred dollars
$300 100
there's free they do it for free because
they want to be associated with that
brand so why the companies come to me
and are willing to pay that much because
when I talk to them I don't lead with
it's going to cost you twenty-five
hundred dollars to do this project right
I talk about what they're trying to do I
prove my knowledge i give them tons of
free advice and ideas to help them grow
their business i give them ideas that
they realize that I know what I'm
talking about and I could be a really
valuable resource for them and I'm
upfront with them you know I'm tell him
if you're if you're trying to work with
entrepreneurs I'm one of the best people
in the world to work with if you're
selling to anybody else that I'm not you
know if you're trying to sell the just
consumers in general don't work with me
I'm not the right person to talk to you
and I'm honest about that and you should
be too but they see the value I give
them lots of great ideas three ideas
that they can't execute without me they
could try and if they want to try then I
don't want those people as clients
anyway you want the people who see the
value who understand what you do who
appreciate it and then when you can get
the price then you can talk about how
much it's going to cost them because
they understand that they really want to
work with you and have you on as someone
that help them out that's when you talk
about price but not right up front and
stop competing on price everybody find
more value to add to your customers so
you're not racing to the bottom having
people undercut you constantly believe
those are watching like the video thumbs
up below leave a comment let me know
what you think ask the question below
make a video response I love watching
your comments come in they really make
my day everyday so thank you and click
on my face to subscribe to the channel
thank you so much I'll see you soon